we've learned about these seven shapes
right and it's kinda seven kind of not
because solo will many of them overlap
actually right for instance we know that
a rectangle is just a special kind of
parallelogram it's a parallelogram with
one right angle once you put one in all
the rest of them turn into right angles
okay
in the same way we looked at most
recently for instance that of rhombus is
a special kind of kite right the kites
got the two pairs of equal science right
and if you make those two pairs equal to
each other then you get a rhombus okay
so even though they're kind of like
seven classes they overlap with each
other right now what we're going to do
is we're going to put them all together
and build one of these because as you
know in real life things don't always
come up in nice neat categorized shapes
they'll be in combinations in those
which is why we spent in a day and
exercise looking at what happens when
you put some of these shapes together
what was that call when you have a shape
that's made up of several other shapes
put together remember starts with a seat
starts with a seat komm percent shape
right so composite shapes a particular
kind of constant shape comes from
building these things okay so I'm going
to show you what they look like so this
is an example of a composition okay
here's a scenario suppose we want to
measure our some kind of space like an
oval which ironically are almost never a
reverse okay or like a patch of concrete
or something like that
okay so it's going to be some awkward
shape like this okay um something like
that's okay so you've got some we don't
looking shape there which clearly like I
suppose what you could do is um you can
put like a big square around the whole
thing but it's not gonna be very
accurate isn't there's going to be all
kinds of it's missing extra bits and so
on so here's the way we're going to
approach it we're going to take this
space and
is like you starting in a corner okay
and we're going to go into this space
and build what's called an offset or a
traverse survey okay now let's have a
look at let's everything out the name
first right a traverse serve it does
anyone know what the word traverse what
does it mean can you take this yeah well
everybody knows yes going along like a
stream and a flat life yeah good good
okay so the idea is that it's a flat
thing I'm sure that's the technical term
um another a more simple way say is
basically you're crossing something okay
so you're crossing a snow field for
instance okay so to traverse this area
right is to go from one end across to
the other okay so that's the first part
of a traverse survey that as you're
going to walk across this traversing is
what you're doing okay but the second
part of it the more useful part is the
offset part and offset is when you have
you know here's a here's a straight line
okay and then you measure distances away
from that straight line and those
distances are the offsets okay so for
instance you might walk along up to here
okay and then you see all right maybe
there's like a landmark like a tree or
like a patch on the ground something
that's important okay
so as you walk up to here and this is
where you'll need partners okay you stop
here
alright and you measure how far you've
gone and this is what you use so these
trundle wheels you are positioned the
start at the bottom and then as you go
forward should click go far enough
hold on this far enough there you go
it's pretty soft but when you're going
and you give me a lot of these you'll
pick it up okay so it's gone around one
meter and clicks so suppose you've watch
from here to here and it's click let's
pick a nice easy number it's click ten
times okay so this distance here is 10
meters you then stop you get your friend
to help you and you look off at right
angles okay so this right angle thing is
really important and you send your
friend off to walk over to this landmark
maybe that's a tree or something like
that it's part of the border here okay
so your friend has walked all the way
over here they all have a trundle wheel
as well okay
and they'll measure that distance
suppose it's eight miles okay and then
you're going to keep on progressing up
through this okay
you're going to move further over here
okay suppose you've counted ten klicks
and then by the time you get up to here
you've counted I don't know say twenty
three klicks
okay so what's the distance from here to
here if I counted ten up to here and
then the 23rd click the deal with the
difference when it will be 13 okay so
you have 13 meters here all right and
then you'll measure the offset in a
different direction so you'll send your
friend off we said that was a right
angle right you'll see just friend off
to this side okay and they'll take
they're trying to a will and they'll
click click click click click click and
say okay maybe I got 20 kicks okay so
I've got that distance now after this is
all completed we're going to have the
Traverse line up here and you're going
to have a bunch of offsets going off
like so okay then you come back okay and
what you can do is if I take all of
those lines the straight lines that are
drawn and I use them as the basis of a
shape okay so now I've got this
approximation with these straight lines
of what the space is looking like okay
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
join all these up I've got this shape
here which is a triangle I've got this
shape here which is a it's a trapezium
because all of these are coming for
right angles they're all parallel to
each other I'm going to triangle along
the end here and then I'm going to
complete the shape like so all right so
this is the offset survey or the
traversal they're both called the same
thing okay so you're going to go out and
you're going to measure this now let me
put a few more numbers on this because
there's a particular way that offsets
are actually measured out because it's a
bit of a pain to crawl this whole thing
okay so let me just put some measure on
see I said that was I was 13 right let's
suppose you got like five
here let's call that distance maybe 12
meters seven meters let's put in two
final measurements okay so here's how I
would like you as you go out there with
your um two wheel and a bit of paper
it's infringement I want you to draw out
three columns okay and here's how it's
going to work we're going to imagine
ourselves again working from the bottom
up to the top walking forward okay so
your first your starting point is zero
okay and then as you go through this
you're going to fill in all of the
distances until you get to the total
right so you're counting clicks we
counted to ten clicks and then you
measured an offset to the left okay and
the offset was eight meters okay then
you kept on going now four is is that I
don't know I guess it's because you want
to get a total and these people are
doing different jobs okay all the
numbers up here are going to be
progressive numbers right so you
remember at this point I said we
encountered 23 clicks so this next
number will be 23 and then you stop and
you measured an offset any other
direction and it was 20 like so can you
see how I'm building this diagram how
will the rest of it look at what would
be the total number of clicks when they
get to this next point here 28 good and
then you take an offset to the left you
keep going what will be the number of
clicks 31 and then you take an offset to
the right and then you take your final
one which is going to make you two
meters forward right so now you can see
this whole the traversal right is 33
meters across and then you've got all
these information which you can build
this shape off and then work out its
area okay clearly the more times you
stop and take a measurement the more
accurate it will be but it obviously
take you longer okay